i'm very excited about our next guest
very excited yes the national ambassador
for young people's literature jason
reynolds yes that's only one the
best-selling author is out with a new
book it's called stunt boy in the
meantime the middle grade graphic novel
is about a boy named portico reeves who
becomes stunt boy it's an alter ego he's
a superhero he keeps his friends and
neighbors safe in his apartment building
uh and he's also coping with uh some
real world issues anxiety his parents
divorce things people go through stunt
boy in the meantime happens to be
published by simon schuster a division
of viacom cbs but jason reynolds is back
with us because the book is very good
and i love jason thank you yes thank you
for being here always good to see you
all this is an exciting book as a lot of
your stories are when they're not
super serious but uh before we get to
the plot i'm very interested in the
dedication this is dedicated to a
ten-year-old you absolutely talk to me
about that
the question is who who was i at 10
right what was going on in my life at 10
years old and for me my life was turning
upside down things were shifting things
were changing the dynamics of my family
uh were definitely transforming because
my parents were going through a divorce
and i had no idea what to do about it
and they really didn't know what to tell
me
to help me cope with it and so i felt a
little you know a little inverted to say
the least
and this story you think could be a
window for kids like you who are going
through that you know what what i hope
it is is that it's a it's a window and a
mirror in that way um but also
a tool that can be used by adults so
that they can read this with their young
people to help process sort of what's
happening in the shifting sands of
family right it's okay that it's
happening right it's one of those things
that sort of happened but how are we
going to how can i figure out how to
write something that young people can
laugh and go on this adventure with and
adults can say this is what's going on
and this is how we can talk about it
jason i think this is so important
because when i was getting a divorce uh
favorite daughter and favorite son were
very young and we made up this
fantastical story that daddy was moving
out because he had to catch the burglar
in the other house so he'd be moving i
mean and when you look at it now i feel
so it's such a terrible thing to do to
children because they kept saying when
is he coming back did he catch the
burglar and i like when you lay out
divorce you say listen for any of these
word combinations think of it like
cracking the code when your parents say
our relationship we love you things
change things won't change these things
happen not your fault yeah these were
words you heard absolutely confused you
even more they they
they definitely confused me more because
there was nothing else behind it to sort
of help me process what was actually
going so if this is not what it is then
what is it what is it right what is it
and i think i just needed a little extra
grounding a little extra footing um and
so you can say it's not my fault whose
fault is it is it yeah
talk about portico having the frets
yeah yeah talk about the frets i think
we all still have the frets what are the
threats anxiety yeah you know it's a way
that we can talk about stomach turning
and to figure out my whole goal was how
can we figure out how to write about
anxiety in a way that feels uh
spot-on in terms of what's happening in
the body it makes it feel as though all
of your organs are being rearranged
right right and for a young person who
doesn't understand how to communicate
that all the time i wanted to give them
the voice to say like i get it when your
stomach's in your throat or when your
brain's in your stomach or when your
heart's in your legs right like in
figuring out how to talk about the
discombobulation of anxiety yeah kids go
through so much and there's so many
children that will identify with this
but a quote comes to mind um it's i
needed a superhero so i became one yeah
sure is that an overarching message to
kids out there that might be searching
for something
not knowing that it could be a mere
reflection it is it is it's to say that
that the things that make us super are
typically the things that are inherent
they're usually not any mutations right
it's compassion
this is this is a young man who is so
empathetic that his superpower is saving
the superheroes he just doesn't want
anyone to be hurt including his parents
yeah and so he's willing to take on more
weight than he should that he deserves
to take on to ensure that he can save
his parents from themselves jason you
say you're right for all children but
you write for black children in
particular what's the distinction in
your mind i write two black children two
blocks right two black children are
right four all children and the
distinction is simple
my my books are love letters to black
kids um uh road maps uh but at the end
of the day the themes in these books are
universal for all children everybody
knows what it is to have a best friend
everybody knows what it is to be sad to
be afraid to be happy like herbert to
have a bully right like herbert right
all of this is real i just happen to
ground them in the framework of black
children because that's what i directly
connect to
do you have one tip in 15-20 seconds for
parents trying to get their kids started
on a life of reading
oh
listen and pay attention to what your
kids are already interested in it is
foolish to fight against the stimuli of
their time you will not win so figure
out how to work with youtube and tick
tock and introduce reading that way okay
that is powerful that is good advice
when we first met you you were single
have you gotten someone yet do i need to
fix yeah what are you talking about hey
[Laughter]
thank you stunt stuntboy in the meantime
is on sale today wherever you like to
buy your books